nice really I'm ready let's do it
because we need to go deeper voyages a
bit grandiose of a word for hours this
is more like start the descent into [ __ ]
fine
we're gonna do great nice Dave you don't
have a name
you're nameless Oh black murky Sharky
and Bob doesn't understand a perfect cop
all right who's driving this
[ __ ] me great who wants to shoot
I can load I I want to shoot this time
all right all right all right I'll man
the power systems
yeah we're power up the the gonna gas it
searing we got okay got power up all the
things I give one guy on one shield here
you got yeah you gotta take now jacking
shoot it
I don't shoot or how do I aim oh sure
dear Oh Tate to come around
wait you love you an essence you haven't
ever shot before and you're going guns
yeah apparently how is it okay and then
space fires okay thanks yeah Oh God
extra engines yeah go faster dude oh
we're going
are you a u-turn Bob why is going up
guys are gunning for us I got a great
feeling about this guy's I make it check
it is driving so why you just chill with
the judgements about naked animals I'm a
prison inmate with the spinny hats
loading the gun I mean guys I like naked
animals just as much as the next guy but
I just don't feel confidence in their
leadership abilities slop you are always
dude I have two engines right now it's
so fast also try not to slam into those
uh shame whiner you're there I get
another oh wow God you must help me get
me go faster sorry this to me
oh Jesus Christ okay all right sorry
receive do we take it on water so we
have holes all right you turn the
engines off why did you why did you do
that brilliant is off there on one no I
was saying I don't know everything
internally and turn the engines off fine
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you want from me but
okay it's whatever slow oh is what I
want from you slow there you go you're
slow we got double shoots now Christ
just for your own sake yeah Oh swordfish
back where you go oh I don't know we
have we had some bad words happening out
here we had a bunch of all the ball the
babies are this ship they don't know
what to do I'm a digger nap I feel like
the one of us that doesn't know what to
do is you I am doing great you've got
you want double speed you want to know I
don't
I very clearly did not evil I will speed
that's why I never wanted anything like
this what are you talking about fasters
is my right patro a little better
always always faster bet that is
patently untrue kill that one fish yet
yes Wow throwing some shade a double gun
because apparently double engine can you
handle double gun can you handle it yeah
Oh Oh fix the hole I'm thankful it's my
job to fix everything Oh God oh that's
sort of the deal when you need an hour
room you fix the holes Marc that's the
deal
yeah that's what always a deal hey if
I'm driving
if I'm driving I'm the captain fix the
goddamn halls and shut up
maybe you should know the guy who's
gonna save your lives
maybe that's an option yeah I find it
hard to leave that non-gun having
markiplier is going to save her save our
lives
hey world back to raddion no one knows
about ya no one I posted that alright
fine
oh my god I know oh jeez
alright is that the OGS of wanting a
double double double fee no no no no no
no no no no line all right second gun
there you go whatever fine I don't know
what you guys want
you're not any guns hahaha what we want
is not changing your guns 1sheeld
garages you got that damn it does the
circuit breakin we're fix the hose Marty
a hole
captain Boggs has fixed the damn holes
Oh Captain Bob I don't put a lot of
stock in Captain Bob I do it's okay he's
a good captain - hey V I want to explore
maybe someone needs to shoot this ice
I'm trying you keep poking turning there
we go
he turning back and forth depending the
ice would return faster is that what I'm
hearing you know faster turn my life no
sorry
rejector e yeah it's going good
oh god we need to shoot faster Oh
more cheese okay Bob see I can I can
flip-flop on the fly like that guys I
can flip-flop only for you Jimmy we're
mode world
I like the alarms play
we have a league where I'm really god
sakes where where's his league you guys
lying
I hear the law here honey
we got Queen a terrible unborn Cui's
here well and quickly dying I'm okay I
need to nap Queen uh terrible yeah Jack
you're gonna have to load your own gun
Oh God's a green penguin oh [ __ ]
clay the terrible has a bequeath of his
presence I don't know how to fix me good
I don't just need to load it Jackie this
coconut thing and put it in I'm trying
thing hell huh how somebody helped
kelvins got now God way to the floor
someone else hey help okay hey we can't
be on this [ __ ] Bullock he's dead oh
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter no
no doesn't want to have a bullet I'm in
bed I'm in more quick all right I'm
gonna come [ __ ] help since apparently
everyone's an idiot he's dead now Bob we
okay yeah Bob just keep driving and get
us to a cave I brought this up against a
wall all right all right wait I'm
properly here I can go now
thank you I guess all low-floor job oh
whatever
Thanks that feels good baby hang on
Bourget let's go to be a penguin are
born wise are gonna be a penguin on
board with this attacking sorry when I'm
bored there check out the board for a
cave up go Jackie oh god okay
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god
great there we go he's dead all right
I'm going for the other one is there
another one I'm tossing this guy there's
multiples oh he said he said okay right
in a way we're gonna go for shields oh
go for shield bacon heart we're gonna K
again we're in a cave if you can't
stretch it on an apparent I can we got
full engine in the cave won't you just
made us leave the cave goddamn ass no I
thought you said they wouldn't do that
why are we just go in the game I don't
know this is my fault
this is the worst [ __ ] underwater
explosion ever happened guys completely
anywhere Ferg's I am [ __ ] I am
brightness suffering and crowding us all
just to end the agony that has this
[ __ ] know what you need to have more
faith in us why why why why let's just
go in the cave let's go to Pat what why
once you leave a cave you can't go back
in the cave well I didn't know that
Bobby could er home razor now we're
orient confer call me um there's
somebody's guns on Columbus we would my
god no we have no cane you want more
like this we've played this game like
two days time we got more guns there you
go and you learned and you learned
nothing none of this before I think I
know a thing or two about what I'm doing
now [ __ ] sake seems like you clearly
don't
okay like we literally have no idea the
struggles that I go through on a daily
basis they're all our struggles we're a
team now we're guy
look at Oh future I'm dealing with right
now oh I don't even mean that doesn't
feel like you are what do you say well
there you go
why not guns go for God's sake no all
right I'm sorry
yours bucket ice thing in front of us
already
shall we go shall we go I'm running away
load the gun
I want the bodies the whole two want a
gun where's ID we have another hole in
here I speak with it somewhere this Dan
I got the dead I got it I got a car oh
thank god we're good woman good
everything's fine guys you guys are so
stressed
you guys are so stressed it's fine out I
think I think we're overreacting - you
nearly killing us I nearly kill us
you didn't kill cui you did it out you
come over here Lotus girl agreed to kill
queef he was actually a vagina for I had
I had two health left I can't take a
vagina fart like that with to hell okay
can't do it I can't do it guys you could
try for the team no I'm not a doctor I'd
literally die I know why you're in here
why all this water leave I should I'm
leaving
well sounds qui should be high squeaky
something squeaky good yeah what I stood
in our wall that's attacking us ah
that's what squeaking okay I got to
gotta Bob got him
actually wait I'm gonna see if there's a
cave over here before we move on okay
which which which which people quit you
have two shots at a time now jack you
could fire twice if you need to yeah
ah sorry quick squid squid yeah yeah and
then when I when I shoot a lot you go
backwards yeah oh yeah that's the thing
oh [ __ ] yeah Musha Musha Musha Musha
Musha Moo kind of all or without even a
case of it so I'll go mark you load all
I do the day okay that's my job wait you
stop you stop you go back you load okay
fine loading is my job jack no one
apparently load is a glazing you stay
off I was just over there on a loaner
program you don't ice come from one sec
rise the ice are not there
ah [ __ ] sake well that sounded if I
could go down the organza I would
penguin penguin she's a big one penguins
penguins on board thank you
hey go [ __ ] about that guy I think I
need to load yourself jack
oh I'm under God we all good yeah we're
good
Jackie yeah we're good go whoever's on
the gun shoot the gun we're good we're
good
all right good teamwork guys cuz
teamwork good teamwork anyone dead yet
no no Morgan I'm sleeping though we're
taking a nap guys you know you really
earned it thank you thank you
hi you definitely deserve you completely
deserve that nap and I feel good about
this I was saying thank you right alysom
we're good shoot the bottle [ __ ] the
bubble shoot the bubble I shot it shut
up
shoot the bubble oh it's annoying every
time he turns and go try different
[ __ ] die oh nice see it's not always
me bad sometimes not so easy being
together sometimes sometimes it's
everyone else that's the problem and not
yeah but most times this is not one of
those times
ah [ __ ] to be clear there's a dense
somewhere I got it you got fixed it Leo
Leo Leo leo we let him win Jesus Oh all
right we're gonna go in the cave and no
one touch [ __ ] all right all right okay
just get out and you go in the cave and
that's it all right
penguin [ __ ] attorney all right I'm
going for it Oh crabs weird crabs
different grab state there's different
crabs here's now oh my god
it's nice ass water look at his ass nice
ass crab juice ah grazie
Percy s Oh nothing normal not nimble
he's so nimble Wow guineas crabs I
realize you're terrifying out this guy's
tough hello Clark
darn oh my god died you [ __ ] I'm at
for health
oh me too okay he's dead I think there
we go let me go first let me go first I
got lots of shrimp there's a shrimp
there's an evil shrimp
ow [ __ ] [ __ ]
taking a goddamn nap because this is
[ __ ] god damn it All Right see ya
I'll fight all this cliche cursing
myself then oh no no you can go take a
nap just don't turn anything on Bob the
shrimp is after me I got engine control
seem full no no you go get your we're
not in the ship you can't do it work so
how you could just shut up oh god
[ __ ] trap
you could just play a lot oh no just you
could just shut it and shut up you could
also be quiet and [ __ ] you well that
seems like a lot of what is with the
shrimp
well [ __ ] are these these shrimp are
horrible yeah thinking this guy is
horrible
I've only a for health less special now
you know now I wait wait three Bob wait
you think I just know roots now hold on
hey there's a gun over here hopper wants
a job
Jack run I got a gun I'm with me there's
a gun there's a gun right here who is
this out out me oh oh oh right click and
pick your wrench back up out whoa what
the [ __ ] ok I gotta go I gotta go guys I
gotta go want that what is this room
it's a rivet you can repair from a
distance I'm feeling better
I know you guys are worried about it
start to feel better got him hey get out
of the bath or at least Cujo scooch over
scooch over all right let's go onward
all your check onward it's high noon get
the right jack it noot noot at high noon
holy save you you gotta know who left a
crab by the ship entrance right okay
it's not my fault
I read Oh God it's tiny crabs it's tiny
crabs you guys okay we have an ad Garbo
I fall why are there crabs everywhere oh
my god giant crab I go to have a bob and
Jack did you leave all these dead not
dead crabs why why'd you do the meat
yeah both of you I was there [ __ ] we're
like deep in cave territory yeah I know
yeah I know we're exploring it not a
[ __ ] a wait we can go up here hang on
hang on ma can we the vengeful
big clam hey [ __ ] it big boy yes to
Gavin for hit watch out oh oh we're dead
instead I got health down here in that
chest
now I've eight health again damn you
know I can survive longer careful it's a
trap it's a crab trap through a bad drop
box traps trap hub it's a crab mimic
who's shooting the ceiling no one to
shoot you to ceiling ended speed up Hey
oh yeah that's that's what we wanted
first no I think yes all engines and
just trying to race past everything do
that I can show you guys right here the
holes and just go as fast as possible
this is what I've been wearing for Bob
I've been waiting for this
can we not leave till we all heal me
let's leave it yeah mark you really
earned that I did I did I got a lot of
hits they're all our breakeven luck hit
sound straight up you straight-up earned
it
thank you Bob I love this complimenting
attitude of yours like this is what it
should be giving me the respect I
deserve
what oh yeah now because I haven't
healed yet cuz I'm not an idiot
oh well way to call everyone else out
please sorry I'm mad at mark not you I
didn't mean why are you mad at me that
seems unfair I'm not mad at you mark I
was just telling you how good you were
doing and I was thanking you for all of
your hard work
I just thank you yeah and how deserve it
all of your all of your resting was
thank you Fame just want to be clear I
sincerely mean all this stuff I'm saying
thank you thank you very much see guys
you guys could learn something from this
there's a little bit of cooperation a
little bit of help we could learn how to
lie
alright hey guys it's my control oh oh
why are we moving I wasn't driving the
thing where you suck full speed yeah
yeah full speed using my you literally
said full-speed sprint through this bad
boy and that'd be the end of it that was
a joke god I am laughs we all laughed we
have got alcohol sales all okay you got
your bubble gun ah double gun yeah no I
got double gun I walk alone oh jeez whoa
wow wow wow here everything floats down
here take a damaged take away rivet dead
pulls region
into the ground right now hard I'm going
touring absolutely [ __ ] on right now
man I know when I'm being [ __ ] on and
this is hardly that ya got a believe I
do it up damage or one going over my
area there your God jail or worrying
teamwork nice job mark you know me get
you some credit there okay what marbles
made for what's full-speed fine [ __ ]
yeah no shields full-speed baby nothing
but engines yes yeah yeah that's what I
talked about a little bit of bravery
goes a long way Oh God we do shields we
don't piss dari effective depth yeah we
need lights lights lights lights place
lights on all right ahead slow and
shield all right we got everything
there's one on everything and everybody
should be happy about that okay oh yeah
this is perfect okay with this okay
it doesn't ever need to be not this okay
actually this is what it'll be then very
boring that's good that's yeah that's
fine that's good babam board Bob Bob all
right full speed ahead mark all right
let's do it
no no no no no gods anybody else we need
to seal we need a guy oh my god one gun
that's all you guys Christ we have a
whole barker dint know I don't know yeah
we do I'm about to have [ __ ] on board Oh
lots of stuff Oh where's old go hots up
by the captain cars I hate this you know
hey I wanna go back to driving
[Music]
that's you that's what you sound like
wow I really hate this new joke look
happy nothing all right I'm gonna get
shields in just a second
yeah my pawn shields down engine one
[ __ ] we're STEMI here no [ __ ] we're
not [ __ ] we got shields we got weapons
we're all good I'm dying I'm dying I'm
dying today not today you're not you're
fine you're fine
not today you're not where's the hole we
got it we got it we got it we got it we
got it we got we got it we got it
there's more he's still attached he's
still attached we run over here neither
shoot any ladders no we got barn out
there when heats up I'm drowning I'm
drowning I'm drowning don't you know we
got we got him got him got him got all
we got it we got it we got it we got it
we got we got nice dick keep shooting
the particles full-speed may have been a
mistake
no we weren't full-speed boy yeah we
were one speed I'm ahead somewhere yeah
I got it we got the hole I got it
they're gone Oh God does a grabby hand
Oh God
I need to go off I need your little word
cheerfully orbitty we're doing
beautifully guys oh god you're gonna
hold on cool this is amazing and I'm
proud a very little health I really need
to heal soon I'm proud hey uh you go
heal I'll take over driving no brah hey
Bob go heal okay you know what you could
drive buddy
how do you drive how do you throw out
the block yeah no that's fine you got it
alright okay alright okay I think I got
this I think I got this you got it yeah
okay
wow that is weird whoa oh boy hey I
don't want to drive anymore Bob all
right I'm back I'm healed by the dry run
to go we have a dead bar don't want to
drink this take the wheel
Oh Mike you boys fix the deck please if
you would please where's this dead who's
got it
I don't know all right I'm gonna fire ye
into the abyss and hope I kill things
ahead of us that's dandy
that's my plan Bob how does [ __ ] do you
drive that thing that was awful yeah
well welcome to my world
yeah Bruce whatever man
I got that - hey drivings almost as hard
as shooting all right I should try my
job dealing with you [ __ ] that's my
job yes I almost forgot mark I think
you're dead on
we are the [ __ ] yeah thank you thank
you [ __ ] that you're laughing happy
to take your side on this one mark I
think you really deserve a little
something
thank God you guys finally I feel like
you finally are getting where I'm coming
from my subject mark I completely see
your perspective I understand why you
are the way you are now it's not your
fault it's not your own you want a boy
it's not Marie it's not your fault
- oh my it's all yours it's not a Phil
this is not your fault Marv you man
bought your soul it's not your fault
this is your fine now your fault how
your fault okay how your fault your
fault dr. ball it's your fault your
fault all your fault based on quality
would you stop but can we go forward
anymore we need the Sun working forward
he said oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
only one word white Wow whoa boy oh boy
oh boy
right there's another one if they're
baby holy man we're good we good we good
ain't arrested and he's arrest me little
she be brain though few barnacles but
we're good
gaping bar yes to get the barnacles
though yeah it looks like we're clear
burns Oh what were [ __ ] that's more [ __ ]
uh-huh
I'll check you I'm honest honest enos
enos enos on seafood as he do I should
do and she do what you do what you do
and there's one over here Oh buddy Oh
buddy Oh buddy Oh be good i word we're
good upstairs like what there's one more
hole no not good
alright we're good now we get away dead
doesn't end somewhere there's it now
there's a hole somewhere back working
we're good we're good ah now there's a
hole somewhere so I'm gonna get it back
on the guns
don't lose hockey things
[Music]
all right you got two holes lots of
holes pigeon holes relationship god damn
it
your ship got my [ __ ] that's my ship
you're right it is your ship you've a
service buddy thank you yeah your fault
it's not your side your fault
second ball ball ball ball ball every
description is just spamming it's not
your fault it's not your fault some
Hanks oh no oh you had mr. shot I missed
a shot and then I'm signing up another
one you [ __ ] turn
oh yeah it's time god there's another
[ __ ] fall now is it shoot the things
shoot the things you should be clear out
it should be clear we're clear we're
clear
oh that's a wall Bob I know I'm just
giving us a little break here walls with
the little trumpet sting they're all
that's your grabbing hand that's a
grabbing hand
Bob let it touch us [ __ ] get away
from it there you go
you guys got it you good I hear giggling
shake-a shake-a shake-a shake-a shake-a
yeah hey Gilly you should be saying
shake a chicken Jesus Christ
hey know if we have a word I got it I'm
on it more holes gotta holes Rock we're
good you get her good okay so far so
good guys I mean I feel like we should
be survivorship woman we are at 3100
fathom Suzanne a new record for ow
no the record is 41 4100 but we're
getting pretty close
hey you want more eyebrows doing this
good before
no no no no design if you want more
speed up down no no no we're good
no why we're doing so well this is
York's fault that we're doing well Kate
Kate you're right cave oh okay yes oh
yeah okay if cave cave okay god that's
not where cavus I'm going okay okay
you go there you go there you go y'all
ready yeah oh hey okay hey why do I
always have to have a flippin bullet
when we go into the undersea cave
what's an undersea trouble bullet guy
dropped this somehow okay well there are
a lot of fast things in this cave oh my
gosh yeah whoa I'm creepy bastard a
futures
oh hey clam Oh oh my god these guys are
quick oh there's so many doesn't really
wishes purple swirl up oh that's nice I
knew Roger realize Robert press R to
view
okay I see em I see look like a barnacle
Slava steady he's going down guys don't
worry I got this yeah I'm reading I'm
reading about this relic sorry no I
think I got this no don't go up
Oh see right here well or else for the
blasted underside O'Neill good thing
really guy was she huh why is there a
snail down here it's easy don't worry
about it okay well scared there's
nothing that way okay there was no point
killing that guy cool is good look at
that buddy yeah it was a little [ __ ]
yeah why why did you not kill the lips
do you problem Bob
cuz it wasn't a little there oh and also
[ __ ] you that's why that's extruded chin
wow I have three health you know what
you know what y'all don't have to elf
now Oh we'll get ready all right I'm
going back [ __ ] it right hey yeah also
take her this good piece
just start leaving leave without be done
yes we got that cave in the beginning of
it I apologize for that look at our hole
we got five more holes yeah that's so
much more integrity than any of us had
before no integrity yeah female
integrity I win this is not your [ __ ]
Bob don't do this to me man it's not
your not your fault no not you man don't
do this to me man it's not your fault
no don't do this it's not your not your
guys want to make it look your way
forever fit you're hot out of my fully
heal I'm fully healed but I just want to
stay in bed cuz I'm a little lazy today
her fault it's yours I'm just gonna stay
in here is that okay yeah we're running
late this is your fault I'm on it's not
my fault I'm putting engines on it's not
my fault it's dark it's dark definitely
going on we don't have any guns over
like I'm getting to it yeah goobers I
know what I'm doing murky where she's
where who worked on were dogs you know
what I'll bet we would be in a lot
better shape if we got in that first
cave oh yeah you know I bet that would
have been awesome for probably fine dick
shields off why not we need shields
every day it looks bad guys mark mark
mark oh god oh god what Gilly rarity why
mark why no I'm dying I'm dying that
seems a little melodramatic about it
yeah we're all dying no we're not
hi guys we're not dying I'm dying I'm
literally drowning to death right now
you're not drowning I'm sorry I decide
literally drowning to death
thank you guys okay auntie I'm literally
drowning to death right now and there
are little spiders also hurting me and
I'm like it's okay I'm dead
so what did we learn mark it's not like
that it's not my fault
no no no keep fighting wait oh hello
every boy
crouched over my body teabag me oh good
a drought if I do black oh no oh gosh is
it really [ __ ] are we well this is
your fault
I want to say I want to say for a very
clear picture all your fault all totally
your fault
all I did you are soluble all I did was
try to make all your fault all I did
that's all I did
it's all your fault
[Music]